so in light of the release of the Logan
trailer which by the way is amazing I
did have the death of 16 million
meetings planned for today but instead
we're going to do the all-new
all-different old man Logan the first
story arc which is called the Zurcher
but I'm click baiting the hell out of
this title because I think it'd be
awesome to do but this story arc really
comes out of a continuation of the
original old man Logan event now for
those of you guys who are familiar with
old man Logan bear with me for a second
you know up and you know up until 2008
really for between the mid-1990s up
until 2008 for around 13 years maybe 15
years Wolverine had always struggled
he'd struggled in popularity for the
longest time he was a 90s character he
was high-octane he was fast paced the
problem was that when Marvel stories
began to shift away from being just
action and focusing more on storytelling
no one really seemed to be able to write
compelling stories about Wolverine I
mean he was popular he was just kind of
a mainstay in Marvel Comics people knew
who he was because his contributions and
in fact by the time he was killed off
and the death of Wolverines story arc he
had appeared as something like by twelve
or thirteen thousand comics so he was
insane how wildly popular he was but at
that point he was in the Avengers he was
on the x-men he was I think was maybe
Mighty Avengers New Avengers he was
everywhere he was all over the place and
so the idea here was to provide a story
that would be compelling for the
character of Wolverine and the
post-civil war landscape in order to
continue to draw an interest in his
character again really just away from
Marvel to kind of build cells build
snails based on a popular character and
so in June of 2008 a writer by the name
of Mark Miller released the old man
Logan's story this was an eighth issue
story arc and what this did is it
focused on a dystopian future where
supervillains had risen up together and
they had basically killed all the
superheroes and the way this worked was
that the supervillains had kind of gone
and attacked heroes but sometimes they
didn't really pair very well because of
spider-man's spider-sense he could he
was he was a very formidable opponent
for almost anybody that he went against
when he went against villains like
Mysterio he was able to fend off against
Mysterio venom was a little bit
different carnies a little bit different
because they could have they could evade
spider-man's spider-sense but
jemaine's here that not everybody's
villains were the right kind of villains
and so under the leadership of the Red
Skull the villains are basically shifted
around they were moved around there
appeared against superheroes that they
were best suited to defeat Mysterio
because of his ability to cast illusions
that can deceive the senses of different
people the five senses of the human body
now he had been tasked with killing off
the x-men and so what Mysterio did is he
traveled to the Xavier Institute and he
duped
Wolverine into believing that forty
villains of the x-men were invading the
mansion and when Wolverine killed them
all
the illusion was lifted and he realized
that he killed all the x-men and so what
this did is it set in motion the ability
for Red Skull to lead all these
different villains and taking over the
world although we were only really shown
North America but the fact remains here
that the basis behind this particular
set of events was that it gave us a
version of Wolverine who for around 50
years refused to pop his claws now
Wolverine himself was under the control
of the Incredible Hulk and the story
continued much of the way that we would
expect it to
Hawkeye showed up and you know basically
had Wolverine join him on a mission to
cast off the super villains using what
he believed to be an underground
resistance group and providing them with
the remnants of the Super Soldier Serum
to basically make them Captain America's
and allow them to fight these different
villains we saw a lot of cool things
along the way we saw that one kid had
stumbled across Scotland's helmet and
was using ants to kill people if they
didn't pay a toll we saw a giant body of
Ant Man or I guess of Hank Pym who was
who had been killed his body was
decaying so on and so forth but the
issue was that you know Wolverines
family lived on a farm that was under
the control of the Incredible Hulk and
his family and so at the end of the
story after the Red Skull was defeated
and they came back
Wolverine found that because he had
taunted the members of the the Hulk
family because he didn't pay his rent
that they effectively killed off
Wolverines family and so in response for
the first time in 50 years he popped his
claws and he killed The Incredible Hulk
now what this did is an allowed Mark
Miller to sort of leave it open-ended
and having Wolverine take the child and
go into the future and more or less call
it a day but during the Secret Wars
event of 2015 Brian Michael Bendis came
back in an effort to basically take old
man Logan and
throw him into the all-new all-different
mobile landscape and gave us a
four-issue old man Logan tie into this
to the Secret Wars event and what this
did is it basically just gave us a
scenario where hold man Logan left his
universe so to speak left his realm and
began traveling around battle world and
seeing all these different versions of
superheroes and he didn't know existed
all these alternate realities like Days
of Future past and so on and so forth
and so in the all-new all-different
marvel landscape when reed richards and
franklin richards and molecule man when
they had basically you know returned
reality to its normal form and recreated
the multiverse it allowed old man Logan
to be thrown into the all-new
all-different lava landscape to take the
place of the previous Wolverine who had
died with x-23 becoming the all-new
all-different Wolverine so it seems a
little weird but basically in the
all-new all-different marvel landscape
old man Logan is a fish out of water and
this is really what Jeff Lemire does
with this first story arc he basically
just tells us that from the perspective
of old man Logan all he remembers is a
white light which of course is when
everything came to an end and then he
simply just woke up in this new reality
he woke up in the all-new all-different
marvel landscape now when he arrives
here he ends up in Times Square now one
thing to keep in mind is that the only
thing that oh man Logan remembers before
this white line was the wasteland was
the original old man Logan storyline
where the super villains had taken over
the world and so when he arrives in this
this future NEC turret when he arrives
in the in the present day an all-new
all-different marvel and he sees the
Time Square is not completely torn to
pieces that there's images of Tony Stark
all over the place it throws him for a
loop because to him this is not the way
things are supposed to be this is not
how they're supposed to be in addition
to this he's still trying to gain his
bearings because he doesn't remember a
lot of what happened before but while
he's perceived by the police due to the
fact that he's just simply standing
around naked when he's attacked with a
Taser suddenly his memory jumps back and
he recalls the events of the old man
Logan universe and so the entire base is
behind
oh man Logan's assistance in you know an
all-new all-different marvel is to
basically prevent that future from
Quetta from happening because right now
this 2015 when the story was written and
this is one of the only times you'll
actually ever see Marvel reference a
specific date within their comics but
you know oh man Logan says is 2015 is a
few years before the
some old man Logan were the
supervillains defeated all the
superheroes and so in his mind he still
has a chance to save the future to keep
that future from happening the
interesting thing about this is we also
get flashbacks from Jeff Lemire he
expands on the original old man Logan
storyline and what he tells us is in
that original met original universe
Wolverine and his son again living on
this farm
we're bartering what they had in order
to gain tools that they need in order to
make money to attend to their farm and
because the tractor had broken down
because the tractor needed a replacement
valve what ended up happening is they
travel to a Down Shield Helicarrier
which was being used by a man by the
name of black butcher now black butcher
is not a wildly important character here
and actually you know once this
flashback is done well rain will even
focus on that and he'll tell us that but
you know black butcher was a c-level
villain at best he was never really a
threat you know it was almost as if you
know your average person you know
decided to wage war against the Avengers
it was on par with you know with the
Masters of evil and so on and so forth
just never really relevant to the
Avengers themselves but in this post you
know apocalyptic society you know in the
land of the blind the one-eyed man is
king and this is basically a
circumstance where with the protection
of the Hulk family black butcher is able
to operate with almost near impunity
he's able to to force people to do
things they wouldn't normally want to do
to force them to give things up in order
to get the things that he wants but he
also runs you know again a good trading
store now the entire basis behind this
is or I guess the entire reason for why
Wolverine has such a deep hatred for
blackboard is butcher is taunting
Wolverine because again in this original
old man Logan story Wolverine doesn't
pop his claws he doesn't fight because
he you know he killed the x-men and so
in his mind he doesn't want to become
that person anymore he doesn't want to
go back to being that dark of an
individual and so where he is more or
less put in a situation where he would
normally fight when black butchers slaps
his son in the end
Wolverine basically walks away he gets
the belt that he needs his son loses his
hat and that's basically yet you know
Wolverine calls it a day now the idea
behind this is Wolverine making the case
to a son that you have to know when to
walk away
if he had killed black butcher then the
whole family would have come after them
like they would have killed them you
know and done any number of things to
their corpses who who knows that family
was wildly deranged and so again for
Wolverine this is a matter of tracking
down the black butcher for retribution
this this really goes to the heart of
the fact that old man Logan is really
just kind of out of his mind here he's
really driven by an obsession which
borderlines insanity and the reason why
I say that is once he tracks down the
black butcher by interrogating and
torturing various people the when he
arrives he immediately cuts off one of
the arms of the black butcher and says
you slap my son now that was the future
black butcher you know that was nothing
the modern day one in all-new
all-different marvel and so the issue
with this is that Wolverine is kind of
teetering on the edge of insanity but
because of this he basically kills black
butcher and what he's done is he's made
a list on his arm of the butcher Bruce
Banner Mysterio and the red skull all
whom he needs to kill in order to
prevent this future from happening and
so what we do here is we basically jump
to his encounter with the Incredible
Hulk now this was a really anticipated
series of events for a couple reasons
the first is that because old man Logan
did not know everything that was going
on in this universe for those of you
guys who have not seen my video on
all-new all-different Hulk what we know
is that under writing of a Greg Pak the
mantle of the Incredible Hulk per se was
basically moved away from from Bruce
Banner as we traditionally knew him and
instead was handed over to to Amadeus
Cho now Amadeus Cho is really more of
like a frat boy kind of Incredible Hulk
he was a jokester he enjoyed his powers
he would hit on women so on and so forth
it was a stark contrast to the Bruce
Banner Incredible Hulk who was wildly
serious and who really just want to be
left alone you know and was very very
dangerous if pushed to the edge but
because of everything that's going on
here because of what's happening now we
basically find Wolverine having tracked
down the Incredible Hulk who again at
this point is Amadeus Cho
now because Wolverine doesn't know this
in his mind the only difference here is
that it's basically just the Hulk and
his goal is to kill the Hulk due to the
fact that the hawk family killed his
family in the old man Logan universe now
again in the mind of Wolverine he can
basically stop all these things from
happening if he kills black butcher his
son
we'll never be a constant if he kills
the Incredible Hulk or if he kills you
know on the day's Channel Hulk then the
Incredible Hulk family will never take
over the West Coast and Wolf rain will
never be under their subservience if he
kills off Mysterio he'll never be
tricked into killing the x-men and if he
kills off you know Red Skull then none
of the events would have happened in the
first place and so it's just an effort
by him to you know prevent the future
from happening the issue with this is
that you know with Amadeus Cho
being much of a joker you know being
being very silly being comedic at the
end of the day he also still recognizes
the threat that old man Logan represents
someone because of the fact that his
fighting prowess is very very strong but
also because of the fact that he's so
quick and he has adamantium claws that
will allow him to cut through you know
the Incredible Hulk with very little
effort and so once the fighting between
the two of them begins to begin to come
to an end once amadeus cho settles down
after having been carried away once
wolverine regains his bearings he asks
him you know are you Bruce Banner and
Amadeus Cho says no I'm not Bruce Banner
I'm Amadeus Cho you have the wrong guy
I'm the new Hulk and so you know Logan's
question is where is Banner and you know
Amadeus Cho basically says I'm not going
to tell you you know I'm not going to
give you that information
now the reason behind this is largely
because of the fact that at this point
in in Marvel Comics you know Bruce
Banner is a regular guy you know he's
not the Incredible Hulk anymore you know
that that power was handed over to to
Amadeus Cho who absorbs the Hulk essence
again I have a video on that which you
can find down in the description but
during his researches and during his
efforts to basically find out everything
that's going on to locate the Incredible
Hulk he also seeks out the refuge of
Hawkeye because again Hawkeye was a
major player in the original old man
Logan story but when he gets there he
basically realizes this is not Clint
Barton Hawkeye instead it's Kate Bishop
Hawkeye now those are guys who are not
aware again I've got a video on her
character down in the description but
Kate Bishop was more or less a member of
the Young Avengers for time but was
every bit as capable as the original
Hawkeye Clint Martin and there was
actually a storyline we were sort of a
passing of the torch not officially in
the sense that you know Clint Martin
gave everything up but in the sense that
he officially recognized that Keith
Bishop was just as capable as he
and so the idea was to to have Kate
Bishop go forward as the all-new
all-different Hawkeye in Marvel Comics
which has received kind of a series of
mixed reviews from different readers but
the fact remains here that with
Wolverine showing up here and looking
for you know looking for clint barton he
doesn't find him and said again he
simply just finds cape bishop there now
this is very confusing to old man Logan
because for him it's supposed to be
Clint Barton it's not supposed to be
Kate Bishop and so it's goal is to
basically track down Clinton because you
know Clint Barton to tell him everything
that's going to happen in the future
that there's going to be danger there
there's going to be you know the the
idea of you know the the plan that he
has is going to be a ruse by the Red
Skull so on and so forth the goal is to
effectively save Clint Barton from being
destroyed and so after conversing with
Kate Bishop he learns how capable she is
she initially asked even to become his
partner but he basically says no I work
alone but in the end has her come along
with him what capable so does is she
catches old man Logan up on a lot of
what's taking place you know she tells
him that that Odin son is gone that in
his place is Jane Foster Thor and yes
it's more or less us as the readers sort
of following old man Logan along as he
picks things up and that was really the
basis behind his character right and
Marvel Comics was during the events of
secret Wars and in the events of all-new
all-different marvel it is a chance for
old man Logan or for us as the reader to
follow him and to see his discovery
through his eyes and to follow along
with him as he makes these discoveries
which we're doing at the exact same time
now and when the two of them arrive to
what's supposed to be the layer of
Mysterio the question is asked by
Wolverine is where is Mysterio where's
he at because again he wants to keep
Mysterio from tricking him and to
destroy the x-men the problem is that s
he begins to sniff out as he begins to
try to locate locate Mysterio he
eventually comes across the trail of old
man Captain America
now this is prior to the Captain America
Hydra story arc and this is prior to the
events of Avengers standoff when Steve
Rogers was returned to being young again
so again for for old man Logan in his
mind the Oh Steve Rogers is supposed to
be young youthful vibrant and a very
capable leader when he shows up in this
all-new all-different marvel landscape
which continues on from Secret Wars you
know Steve Rogers
and so again it's very strange to him
it's a mishmash of different things but
the idea is to basically talk wolve rain
down from his quest to go through and
kill so many people
but you know old man Logan says that
he's preventing a future from happening
he's effectively saving the future but
to the minds of Steve Rogers to the
minds of Kay Bishop this man's insane
similar because of the fact that he's
killing innocent people to preserve a
future that's not guaranteed to happen
now this is where things get a little
bit murky in the realm of of Marvel
Comics so the reason why is because with
Secret Wars having been an event that
was planned out over the course of a
couple years or so but happened long
after I guess was planned out long after
the events of old man Logan the question
becomes did Secret Wars happen in the
original old man Logan universe if it
did happen then oh man Logan has a point
here if it didn't happen then he's
basically a man off his rocker because
there's no guarantee that those things
are going to happen but the result is
the question I guess the question that
that old man Logan has is what happened
to the Wolverine in this reality what
was going on with him and so what they
do is they take him to the body of the
original Wolverine from the mainstream
Marvel Universe and show him that he's
dead that he was encased in adamantium
and so what this does is this tells old
man Logan the future that you come from
is not guaranteed to happen because the
past that you remember is not the past
that happened here now again this is
basically where things begin to get a
little murky and it requires a little
bit of expansion here after old man
Logan or when old man Logan was
originally written it was given to us as
an alternate reality and so while we
weren't really given the backstory to
the events during you know old man
Logan's time as will reign alongside the
x-men we were kind of left to assume
that it was similar to the original you
know to the mainstream Marvel Universe
but we weren't explicitly told here but
in the mind of old man Logan the past of
this universe is the same past as his
original universe but when he discovers
this body of himself in Kayson
adamantium as he died and the original
you know death of Wolverine story arc
he's basically told this is not your
future and this is not your past this is
not even your home reality you are in a
different universe than your a
old man Logan's story so hopefully that
makes sense to you guys at least least I
really hope it does but the basis behind
this is to effectively tell old man
Logan what you're doing here isn't right
because there's no reason to believe
that Mysterio would kill off or you know
trick you into killing off the x-men
there's no reason to believe that you
know the black butcher would grow up you
know would eventually become subservient
to the Incredible Hulk and there's no
reason to believe that the Incredible
Hulk would enslave the entire eastern
seaboard of the United States and so
what this does is effectively allowed
Wolverine to kind of I guess allow old
man Logan to sort of give up this quest
with the background thought of keeping
his feature from coming to fruition now
he won't necessarily be as active as a
years in the story in trying to keep the
future from happening it'll really be
more of an exploration with regards to
him looking at the world around him the
problem with this is that almost
immediately after he sets off he's you
know he's approached by storm and the
x-men who were again traveling around
trying to grab those mutants who have
not been attacked or not been so you
know exposed to the Terrigen mists and
who haven't quite died yet so with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end
um I know it can be a little daunting
with regards to the old man Logan story
I know it can be a little bit confusing
I did the best I could trying to make
sense of all this but if you guys have
questions feel free to ask them down in
the comment section and I'll answer them
as best I can because again you know
Jeff Lemire kind of relies on a lot of
existing information and it can be a
little bit you know disconcerting
jumping back and forth between alternate
realities past and present so on and so
forth but without being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end and yeah I
will catch you guys later
peace